>> AMERICAN VOTERS KNOW EXACTLY
WHO TO TRUST WHEN IT COMES TO
CRIME.
IT'S NOT EVEN A CLOSE CONTEST.
REPUBLICANS SMOKE DEMOCRATS WITH
A MONSTER 22-POINT ADVANTAGE
AMONG REGISTERED VOTERS WHEN IT
COMES TO WHO DO A BETTER JOB
HANDLING THE SURGE IN VIOLENCE.
67% OF VOTERS RANK CRIME AS ONE
OF THE TOP ISSUES THIS MIDTERM
ELECTION.
IT'S NO WONDER VOTERS ARE
WORRIED.
A SHOCKING VIDEO OUT OF
PHILADELPHIA THIS PAST WEEKEND
SHOWS DOZENS OF TEENS STORMING A
LOCAL STORE AND COMPLETELY
RANSACKING THE PLACE.
CRIME IS SO BAD IN NEW ORLEANS
THAT THE POLICE DEPARTMENT IS
FORCED TO RECRUIT CIVILIANS TO
MAKE UP FOR THE SEVERE STAFFING
SHORTAGE.
THE CAREER CRIMINAL, ONCE THE
POSTER BOY FOR NEW YORK CITY'S
CARELESS BAIL REFORM, JUST
ARRESTED BY POLICE ON AN
ATTEMPTED MURDER WARRANT.
THE POSTER BOY FROM A DEMOCRATS
ISSUE ENDS UP GOING DOWN HEART
IN A SCANDAL -- GOING DOWN HARD
IN A SCANDAL.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU HAVE TO
ASK YOURSELF, WHY ARE THEY IN
THIS MESSAGE, PEOPLE THAT
NOTHING ABOUT CRIME, LAW
ENFORCEMENT, DECIDE WE'RE GOING
TO DO THIS SOCIAL JUSTICE THING.
WHY ARE WE AS AMERICANS PAYING
TAXES, TOLERATING THIS KIND OF
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR WHERE THERE
ARE NO CONSEQUENCES?
OUR LEGAL SYSTEM IS NOW SO
CONSUMED WITH THE RIGHTS OF THE
CRIMINAL THAT WE GIVE THE
CRIMINAL TOP BILLING.
IT'S THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT THE VICTIMS JUSTICE
THE VICTIM NEVER CHOSE TO BE
PART OF IT.
WE CODDLE CRIMINALS IN THIS NEW
SOCIAL JUSTICE MILIEU AS IF
THEY'RE THE VIOLATED AS OPPOSED
TO THE VIOLATORS.
THEN WE DENY THE TRAUMA OF THE
VICTIMS.
THAT'S ALL FINE AND DANDY,
RIGHT?
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
YOU'VE GOT TO REFORM THE BAIL
LAWS, PUT JUDGES AND DAs IN
OFFICE WHO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
STOP WITH THIS SOCIAL JUSTICE
NONSENSE OR YOU'RE GOING TO
SUFFER CRIME.
CRIME DOESN'T JUST DESTROY YOUR
LIFE OR YOUR FAMILY'S LIFE.
IT DESTROYS NEIGHBORHOODS AND
CITIES AND BUSINESSES.
IT'S DESTROYING AMERICA.
IF WE LOOKED AT WHAT WENT ON IN
THE UK DURING THE QUEEN'S
BURIAL, THAT WHOLE THING FOR 12
DAYS, WE DIDN'T SEE PEOPLE
HATING EACH OTHER.
WE DIDN'T SEE SIGNS OF PROTESTS.
THERE WAS UNITY.
THERE IS NO UNITY IN AMERICA.
AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BROUGHT
US THIS DIVIDE WHERE, YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE ALL THERE, WE'RE ON THE
SUED OF THE CRIMINAL, WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE BAIL TO THE
CRIMINALS, AND WE'RE PAYING THE
PRICE.
IT'S ABOUT TIME WE GOT THEM OUT
OF OFFICE.
>> HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO A WAWA?
>> YES.
>> IT'S A RELIGIOUS INSTITUTION
IN PHILADELPHIA.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK WE SHOULD
GIVE THE TEENS THE ELECTRIC
CHAIR BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY DID
TO SOFT PRETZELS.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THE FEELINGS
OF PEOPLE IN PHILADELPHIA WHEN
THIS HAPPENS?
>> NOT ABOUT THE ELECTRIC CHAIR
AND THE PRETZELS.
I WENT TO COLLEGE ON THE
MAINLINE.
I SPENT TIME IN PHILLY AND THE
SURROUNDING AREA.
>> HMM.
>> OH, THE MAINLINE?
I UNDERSTAND PEOPLE ARE UPSET
ABOUT THIS.
I GREW UP IN THE CITY.
IT'S DEVASTATING ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON.
I DON'T FEEL SAFE ABOUT BRINGING
MY DAUGHTER ON THE SUBWAY.
MY MOM HAD ME ON THE SUBWAY
EVERY DAUGHTER.
>> OH, I THOUGHT YOUR MOM
DELIVERED YOU ON THE SUBWAY.
>> EVERY DAY.
THERE WAS ALWAYS SOMEONE AROUND
TO HELP WITH THE STROLLER,
RIGHT?
IT WAS COMPLETELY CIVILIZED.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT THE CASE
ANYMORE.
IN TERMS OF THE EFFECTNESS OF
THESE ATTACKS, THESE DANGEROUS
LIBERAL POLICIES, WE HAVE YET TO
SEE IF IT'S EFFECTIVE IN TERMS
OF WHAT HAPPENS IN THE MIDTERMS,
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO NECESSARILY CLOSE THE
LOOP TO SAY WE'RE FOR SOME
REFORMS.
WE BELIEVE IN SOCIAL JUSTICE
REFORM, BUT WE THINK X, Y AND
Z --
>> SOMEBODY TELL ME WHAT IS
SOCIAL JUSTICE?
>> THAT PEOPLE AREN'T
INCARCERATED FOR CRIMES THEY
SHOULDN'T BE.
>> THAT'S WHY THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS THERE, TO
DETERMINE WHO'S GUILTY AND NOT
GUILTY.
>> AND LAWS OVER THE DECADES
THAT THERE WERE TOO HARSH, THAT
BLACKS WERE --
>> I DON'T AGREE LAWS ARE TOO
HARSH.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON
TODAY, THEY'RE TOO WEAK.
>> CONSERVATIVES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY AGREE THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE REFORMS.
>> OH, REALLY?
LIKE WHO?
>> RUDY GIULIANI.
>> RUDY GIULIANI, THE TOUGHEST
PROSECUTOR THIS CITY HAS EVER
SEEN.
>> RIGHT, BUT WHO ALSO TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
PEOPLE UNFAIRLY --
>> ALL RIGHT.
GIVE ME AN IDEA.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO CHANGE?
>> ARE WE MOVING OR --
>> I WAS WAITING FOR YOU TO SAY
SOMETHING, BUT IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SAY, I'LL
GO TO AINSLEY.
AINSLEY, SHE BROUGHT UP PEOPLE
ARE LOCKED UP FOR POT.
THEY ALWAYS TROT THAT OUT.
>> BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
>> YOU BASICALLY HAVE TO MURDER
SOMEONE TO GET ARRESTED AND
STAND BEHIND BARS IN NEW YORK.
THE GUY TRYING TO PROTECT HIS
BODEGA, THERE'S MURDER CHARGES,
AND WHEN PEOPLE TRY TO PUSH
ALVIN BRAGG, HE CHANGES HIS MIND
AND DROPS THE CHARGES.
THAT'S WHAT IT TOOK.
HOW MANY OTHER PEOPLE ARE OUT
THERE THAT THE MEDIA DOESN'T
KNOW ABOUT, CHARGED WITH MURDER,
BECAUSE THEY DEFENDED THEIR
BUSINESS?
THAT GUY WORKED EVERY SINGLE
DAY, SO HARD TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE FOR HIS FAMILY, AND SOME
GUY COMES IN, THREATENS HIM WITH
A KNIFE, HE'S KILLED, BUT
EVERYBODY DEFENDS THE VICTIM.
NOBODY CARES ABOUT THE VICTIM.
WHAT ABOUT THE BOY WHO DIED, RUN
OVER BY THE CAR, ALLEGEDLY,
BECAUSE HE WAS-REPUBLICAN?
THE MOM AND DAD HAD TO BURY HIM,
AND SAID WE WILL MISS YOU EVERY
SINGLE DAY, AND THE GUY IS
WALKING THE STREET WHO DOES
THIS.
THIS IS WHAT WE HEAR TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
ONE DAY IT WILL BE YOUR
CHILDREN, OR MY CHILDREN.
WE LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY.
I HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THAT.
I LIVE IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
MY FRIENDS SEE YOU WALKING THE
STROLLER, AND THEY THINK YOU'RE
CUTE.
MY FRIEND CAMILLE ALWAYS WANTS
TO TALK TO YOU, BUT SHE'S
NERVOUS.
>> HA-HA-HA.
>> THESE ARE THE THINGS WE WORRY
ABOUT ON OUR STREETS, THE UPPER
EAST SIDE.
YOU'RE RIGHT, WE CODDLE THE
CRIMINALS.
WHAT DO WE EXPECT?
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS SAY, NO BAIL,
DEFUND, DISMANTLE, REIMAGINE,
RELEASE THE VIOLENT CRIMINALS,
WE'RE CODDLING THEM, AND THAT
TEACHES THEM THAT YOU CAN GO
INTO A STORE, A WAWA, DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT, AND CHARGES
WON'T BE PRESSED AGAINST YOU.
CALIFORNIA, SAN FRANCISCO.
YOU SAW THE BEAUTIFUL STORES
THAT ARE ROBBED.
THEY WALK OUT, AS LONG AS THEY
DON'T TAKE A THOUSAND DOLLARS
WORTH, THEY'RE FREE.
>> I BELIEVE THAT IMMIGRANT
BODEGA OWNER HAD TO FLEE THE
COUNTRY.
>> DID HE REALLY?
>> YEAH.
HE LEFT FOR THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC.
>> YOU MEAN, NOBODY IS THERE
RIGHT NOW?
LET'S GET OUTTA HERE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE CONSEQUENCES
OF A CANCEL CULTURE IN THAT
THERE'S A CERTAIN KIND OF
CENSORSHIP IN WHICH YOU CAN'T
TALK ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS.
I DON'T AGREE THAT DEMOCRATS
WANT MORE CRIME.
I HONESTLY THINK WE HAVE ALL THE
SAME GOALS, BUT OUR SYSTEM, WE
DON'T AGREE ON IT, AND IT HAS TO
DO WITH THE PROGRESSIVE MINDSET
THAT PUNISHMENT, JUSTICE, IS
SOMEHOW MEAN, RIGHT?
IF YOU COULD SEE THROUGH THE
POSTER BOY SCAM.
IF YOU WERE TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT IT, YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN
CALLED A RACIST.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE VANDALISM
SPREE IN WAWA, YOU CAN ONLY SAY
TEENS, YOU CAN'T SAY ANYTHING
ELSE, RIGHT?
A MOB OF TEENS.
YOU CAN'T SAY ANYTHING ELSE.
WHAT THAT DOES, IT PREVENTS YOU
FROM GOING DEEPER, TALKING ABOUT
THESE PROBLEMS.
ONE, WE HAVE A TERRIBLE
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN WHICH
TEACHERS UNIONS PUT THE STUDENTS
LAST.
RIGHT?
THAT'S A SYSTEMICALLY RACIST
SYSTEM, BECAUSE ONLY PAR BLACKS
IN CITIES LIKE PHILLY ARE LEFT
WITH THAT OPTION.
SO YOU HAVE LOTS OF BLACK KIDS
IN WAWA, RIGHT?
EDUCATION TOO.
BLM ACTIVISTS REALIZE THAT THEY
MADE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, WENT TO MANSIONS, TO
FRAUD, WHATEVER.
THE LAST THING YOU BROUGHT UP,
THE DEVALUING OF ANYTHING OF
VALUE.
I NOTICED IN WAWA, CARJACKINGS
THAT END IN JOYRIDES.
IT'S NOT ABOUT TAKING THINGS,
BUT DESTROYING THINGS.
THE MOB THINKING HAS AN IDEA
THAT IF YOU'RE NOT PROTECTING
SOMETHING, THEN IT PROBABLY
ISN'T WORTH IT ANYWAY.
SO YOU'RE SEEING VANDALISM IN
SCALE.
IT'S THE REVERSE OF THE -- WHAT
DO YOU CALL IT?
THE BROKEN WINDOWS CONCEPT.
IT'S THE OPEN WINDOW CONCEPT.
COME ON IN, TAKE WHATEVER YOU
WANT, BECAUSE AFTER THE $900
DECRIMINALIZATION THING, NOTHING
IS WORTH ANYTHING.
WHY FIGHT FOR ANYTHING?
I WANT THAT.
I COULD TAKE IT.
WHY NOT?
WHEN WE DECIDE THINGS AREN'T OF
VALUE ANYMORE, THEN THEY AREN'T.
IT'S ALL A TRUST BETWEEN US THAT
WE DECIDE WHAT IS IMPORTANT, OF
VALUE.
WITH WE STOP PROTECTING THAT,
THEY DON'T CARE EITHER.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK YOU'RE
SEEING.
I THINK YOU'RE SEEING A CHAOS
BROUGHT UPON BY JUST THE
DEVALUING OF CULTURE.
>> ARE YOU SAYING THEY DIDN'T
WANT THE TASTYKAKES THEY STOLE?
THEY JUST TOOK THEM ANYWAY?
>> A LOT OF TIMES, STUFF ISN'T
TAKEN, THEY JUST SMASH T